مرحبًا بالجميع
أعتقد أنني أعتقد أنني حصلت أخيرًا
على حل لمشكلة ترتيب
نعش الملكة أه المشكلة
التي نواجهها حقًا هي أنني أفكر في
حوالي 30 ساعة حتى يتمكن الناس
من تجاوزها  هو أن هذا غير معقول ، لذا
أعتقد أن الطريقة التي يتم تشغيلها بها
الآن هي أن الناس يقومون بتنظيف
جانبي التابوت وهم
يقومون نوعًا ما بآخر احترامهم ، وهذا
ليس بالكفاءة التي نعطيها للملكة
حصلت على الكثير  مساحة السطح أكثر
مما نعطيها الفضل في أه نحن بحاجة
للتخلص من هذا ، لذا فإن ما أقترحه
هو أن نضع الملكة نحن جبل
الملكة في ذراع آلية كاواساكي
ونكسر جميع النوافذ في أه
وستمنستر  أه في القاعة
ونحرك الملكة في حلقة كاواساكي ،
يحصل الجميع على رؤية جيدة لها
أه وبهذه الطريقة أعني
أن المنظر سيكون سريعًا ولكن يمكنك
رؤيته أه بهذه الطريقة يمكننا التعامل معه  حول
أه أعتقد أنه 80 مشيعًا في الثانية
لذا هذا جيد جدًا
يمكن أن يتعامل مع الدولة بأكملها التي يبلغ
عدد سكانها 67 مليون شخص في غضون
ثلاثة أيام تقريبًا ، لذا فهذا جيد
جدًا في الوقت المناسب تمامًا للجنازة ،
أخبرني بما تعتقد أنه لا أعرف
إذا كان أه أنا إذا أردنا التخلص من
هذا  الأرض ربما يتعين علينا أن
نبدأ قريبًا جدًا